salveee youtubers
oggi faccio un velocissimo video
per dvd un paio di cose e per la
sorpresa che avevo detto ad
alcuni canali fatto
allora purtroppo sono in ritardo
con
vedi video e rosso emmy scusa
tantissimo perché el
la registrazione di
delle erbe il cortometraggio su
esame come potete vedere va
avanti ma molto a rilento
perché alcuni video ci mette 20
minuti per estrarle
esco cerco di stare nei dieci
minuti di video per non divide
le due parti che mi secca
e qua ci sono le riprese come
potete vedere scandalo spero si
veda da
mappa hypercam 2
here's to the fate con ali green
screen me per quello che ci
metto tanto con questa belen una
porcheria allucinante uno
squallore assoluto che alba hot
giusto bene per l'ascolto da
nomen omen
già ho detto
c'è un motivo per cui si chiama
scuro provaccia la mia casa di
produzione
alla veloce vi faccio vedere
subito perché ero così voglio
farlo deve avere i giochi a cui
gioco io di sole perchè non ho
mai detto ma molti me lo
chiedono
mi consigliano giochi da giocare
belli allora me li faccio vedere
ditari ereditario wall tour che
ho preso da poco di carico tra
loro finito tutto centopercento
e' venuto sto giocando adesso mi
amico che ha venduto la chitarra
da poco quindi
mi sto scialando parecchio
poi io adoro i giochi di ruolo
quindi hai detto mondo che non
sarà perfetto ma mi piace
perchè città ci sono tanti
oggetti tante armature tante
cose belle perchè per me il
gioco di ruolo il personaggio
deve essere proprio
c'è nella parte principale
dopo, sto ripassando dev'essere
caratterizza bile
poco ma tanto c'è oggi d armi
c'è tra quindi
eletrodo sotto quel punto di
vista abbastanza bello
poi siccome ho poco tempo ho
avuto la brillante di di
scaricarmi
dracon sei jocuri jeans che
emma dura poco mi hanno detto di
dalle 40 le 60 ore quindi ho
fatto una cosa molto
intelligente
torchlight un giochino tipo
diablo 1 in 3d molto bello
e poi altre vabe diablo 2
classico diablo 2 centri alte
sport tutto le fortezze ad
esempio a quel gioco online e
leopoldo work as cordialmente
gioco con un mio amico
adamello cello
vi dico prima di tutto vi
ringrazio per tantissime cose
oddio spero di stare i miei
15 minuti ma non credo
fb valitazione canali a 1000
iscritti 1300 39 anche se qua
non ho aggiornato 70 unisim
opposizione con ip script in
assoluto e ti ringrazio
tantissimo il vivace e tutti se
potessi dopo sono fidanzato e
non
la legge non l'ho
vorrei ringraziare in
particolare term il magnifico
mangaforever 0
nizza 900 39 federicoooo
212 hanno fatto dei video
in cui mi hanno citato
federico ha fatto una canzone
aiuto mi sparta remix lui ha
fatto una recensione su man-ga e
poi dovuto fare un punto se
alimento sulla recensione
perchè a molti non è piaciuta
perché la capa come me mi
disegni facciali cecina mare con
la recensione di un manga
l'abilità l'ha fatta come me ea
molti non è piaciuto allora lui
ha dovuto rifare i get fare un
altro video di chiarimenti mi
dispiace poverino non vedo
perchè debbano di vedere quelli
youtobe ma lasciate
fare ma perchè dovete fare him
bimbiminchia da
poi mangaforever 0 che ringrazio
perchè lo conduce diciamo e' un
mio contatto da un po'
emblemi casa anche se non un
contatto diretto lui ha fatto un
video con i migliori youtubers
italiani ha messo messe mauil
uscire al più make up now
ringrazio tantissimo anche
secondo me non dovevate perchè
non sono a quei livelli loro
hanno tipo le 100 1000 iscritti
- 1000
dvd gratis ma non c'era bisogno
e anche them il magnifico quel
con la sua porco
xii pradaccio andare
cioè mi ha messo
mi ha citato che vi ringrazio il
gatto però me lo dovete dire
perché questi video li trovo
per puro caso scrivendo yotobi
su
su youtube vengono tutti i video
in cui nelle stanze c'è il mio
nome alcuni che non centro
niente i bastardi mettono nelle
stanze
non in tv clio make up win
uscito famosi youtube così
quando uno scrive quelle tonon
subito bastarde 3 io li
ringrazio lo stesso perchè si
mettono all
il mio nome vuol dire che mi
considerano famoso
e io vi ringrazio
il fan club
spacca ecco reticolo arcuri
582 scritti e si è dato una di
discussioni varie quindi vi
ringrazio così un contatto
diretto con voi
non avendo più nessun mio
contatto di
via msn
posso parlare con voi qui e sul
mio canale 4
poi volevo ringraziare
una persona che non so chi sia
se mi scrivete yotobi che io do
you to main con gaulle correggi
col
molto brutto
ma pur ma ti pare che c'è io
topi forse cercavi molto
combattuta scritto io come forse
cercavi o
ottobre che è tutt'altra cosa
pago
che cazzo di fare
se mi scrivete gli atomi di
kitty
via 11 penne ai funghi con
alcuni
perchè capita a volte
la mia pagina di nichi clivia e
spettacolo youtube - youtube
repubblica tante tocana
recensioni su film sul disagio
che la prima volta che l'ho
visto
avere un infarto mi è venuto un
erezione spettacolare to wow
qualcuno ha fatto
la mia pagina di vicky figli a
carico
questa pagina è stata
cancellata
apposto l'elenco delle relative
cancellazione degli spostamenti
viene riportato di seguito per
informazione
roberto mura che credo sia uno
dei moderatori di ciriè ha
cancellato yotobi per pagina
vuota di prova senza senso
tautologia 1 ita o stupidaggine
io ringrazio che c'ha provato
perchè purtroppo quando c'è
scritto chia tentato di fare
questo me lo ringrazio anche
solo per un reciproco
non dovevate che non sono così
famosa alcuni dicono il biondi
ma voi siete impazziti l'unico
dio che ce e quello del video di
donload zone e poi accolto
esatto
niente
la cosa principale che volevo
dirvi e conquer 4 aiutino prima
che albergo dividendo parte
voglio fare per ringraziarvi so
che non è molto ma voglio fare
un piccolo concorso voi
praticamente faretto una
recensione di un film
squallido mi raccomando che non
sia
sto povero tuailait e che tutti
mi dicono dire ci si è non lo
recensisco troia it e' un film
discreto non è niente di che ma
loro cisco tutti che vogliono
che ce ci scappa
io sono uno di quei pochi a cui
è piaciuto
ma perché news è un film
decente neri che gli attori sono
bravi larry abbastanza carina
e sono tra quei pochi che
aspettano
in una quello nuovo
e io sono sapevi sono un per un
posto nuovo per un mezzo sono
una ragazza e quindi mi piace
aspetto youtube e new moon è
con me come le ragazzine che si
strappano i capelli quando
guardano robert pattinson mattia
ebay ti devo dire in fretta
e' un voi farete la recensione
di un film
squallido mi raccomando
l'importante nn con due cose
dovete seguire 1 potete farla
come volete
però unlock non dovete farla di
un film che ho già fatto
2 è un
%
c'è un limite di tempo
dovete farla
eni
in due settimane
c'è vi do due settimane di
tempo perché mi sembra credo
sia abbastanza se non lo è meno
di te
il 21 io chiudo lei iscrizioni
allora se siamo in più di 10
io faccio il concessami -10
dispiace ma non lo facciamo
troppo pochi quindi dal 22 in
poi io inizierò chiuderò le
cose inizierò a parlare
c'è afa a buttarle
per chi vincerà prendere un
video omj paradiso 1 canto a
però mi darà il video
e lo metterò commento che nel
mio canale non è molto buono se
solo per far per ringraziarvi io
faccio così
ho visto che molti fanno
recensioni venuto perché no
potete farlo del film che volete
leggere commenta importante che
non l'abbia già visti
un'altra cosa spero di non
uscire egli non uscire da
lol thank u n'altra ultima cosa
vorrei togliere
è un paio di mie recensioni
soprattutto quella di palermo
milano il ritorno
mortal kombat 2 e quelle dei
giochi vecchie
per chi è sono vecchie fanno
schifo non fanno ridere sono
veramente stupida soprattutto
quella di milano palermo fatto
delle battute che non so neanche
perchè le abbia fatte forse sul
momento non mi veniva
nient'altro di intelligente
sopratutto quella sull'accento
sicigliano molti me l'hanno
criticata e di giuro avete
ragionissimo e mi dispiace
non so chi
cazzo di battuta sia quella dove
dico che
l'accento di siciliane del
bangladesh ma
vi giuro
il barolo più razzista che non
l'abbia mai detta qui non l'ho
mai detta blue giuro
e niente
legge probabilmente tornerò
alla fine di far on più avanti
meglio che me ne faccio del
farmaco minuto
rt ringrazio mi raccomando
mettete nella recessione come
video di risposta a questo video
e io nascero' livido di rispondi
100 dvd disposta aperti così
potete mettere come volete
lo fanno vabe faccio che
link aggiungerli va e meglio
mi raccomando fatele da una
parte sola
il pastaio vi ringrazio
se ci sentiamo la prossima i
video arriveranno dal pozzo
volta farò una recensione di un
film
vi ringrazio saluto